for live local now the community risk is
low at this time the transmission route
is different than covid the health
district working to ease any fears as it
monitors the first possible case of
monkey pox in clark county good
afternoon thanks for joining us at four
i'm kirsten joyce and i'm christian
casadas victoria saha begins our team
coverage here at four o'clock she's live
now in the newsroom with a breakdown of
this initial case and what it could mean
for our area victoria
yeah with the news of the first possible
case of monkey pox here the southern
nevada health district wants to
emphasize how crucial it is to know the
signs and symptoms they also say it's
being considered a national outbreak
the health district is reporting this
potential case is from a man in his 20's
who recently traveled domestically he
was not hospitalized and is isolating at
home the health district is conducting
contact tracing although cases are
slowly starting to pop up in different
states kimberly freinage from the health
district says the risk of exposure isn't
as worrisome as kovid the transmission
route is different than covid it is with
close skin to skin contact or prolonged
face-to-face exposure so at this time
our community risk is low but something
that we should be aware of if we were to
identify any close contacts here in
clark county we would monitor um be in
touch with that person ask them to take
their temperature twice a day for a full
21 days due to southern nevada being a
popular travel destination frenich says
there could be more monkey pox cases in
the near future
when it comes to testing for this virus
this person was seen at an outpatient
clinic doctors took samples from the
lesions that were evident on his skin
those results should be coming back
within 72 hours christian